some say they qualify but can't get a
shot while others have had their
vaccination appointments
canceled 8 news now reporter madison
kimbrough joins us live in studio
tonight
with the latest madison yes sasha some
of our viewers reached out to us sharing
some of their concerns about the
cancellations of these vaccine
appointments
places like sun city anthem and
henderson had to postpone their
appointments
and while we are experiencing a shortage
of doses
health officials say it's just temporary
the state of nevada is receiving limited
doses of the coven 19 vaccine
from the federal government each week
many vaccination sites are having to
scale down
because of the limited allocation we are
set to receive next week
on friday the state reported that more
than 137 thousand nevadans have received
the covid19 vaccine
for the past five weeks nevada has
received approximately 36 000 doses a
week
the goal 18 thousand doses per day
a goal we are far well behind at this
point
the federal allocation should be based
on population
which is what we were told it would be
and our belief is
or our assessment is that it is not
being done
based on population from the federal
government so
we have been making requests through
fema
the city of henderson tweeted this out
on friday letting people know that they
were going through a temporary coveted
vaccine shortage
sun city anthem being one of the
affected areas as of now that location
is still able to administer the vaccine
through this week
but will stop in february the cdc shows
that nevada is second to last in the
country for people getting their
vaccines
so as far as more doses coming in weekly
it's still unknown
we are communicating um regularly
through the emergency management system
in the state
or in the nation for the additional
doses we need
and as the um uh white administration
takes
further control of this process in the
the weeks ahead we
we anticipate um having more
conversations with him as well
and a quick reminder appointments will
be available at cashman center again on
monday
the site has temporarily closed this
weekend for improvements
reporting in the studio madison
kimbrough 8 news now